imagine you're in a game show with three
doors one has a car and the others have
goats you pick a door say number one and
the host reveals a goat behind another
door number three they ask if you want
to suit your choice to door number two
so do you switch most people think it
doesn't matter whether you switch or not
but switching increases your chances of
winning initially your chosen door has a
one in three chance of winning while the
others together have a two and three
chance the host reveals a losing door so
they're filtering out the bad choice
leaving the other door with a two and
three chance of winning it's easier to
understand if there are 100 Doors your
initial Choice has a 1 in 100 chance of
winning while the other doors have a 99
out of 100 chance the host then filters
out the options for you by eliminating
98 bad doors they know don't have the
prize this leaves the remaining door
with the rest of the odds a 99 out of
100 chance of having the prize